okay we appreciate you returning thank
you uh you're our first interview
in the new spot by the way Super Bowl
week interviews brought to you by Def
Jam shout out to Def Jam uh but I wanted
to talk to you because there was a clip
that went viral of you recently yeah you
were on Vlad and it was essentially you
saying now I'll let you kind of women
have a certain time period to report if
they've been sexually assaulted yes was
it an hour it was an hour to report it
okay now I want you to yes I'm going to
collaborate please because that sounds
crazy yeah this sounds crazy and the
reason why and everybody that hit me
from all over the world
was basing everything on their personal
experience
so I did this interview with this young
lady and we I I explained I explained to
her what I felt right and I explained
and I listened to what she said and what
I'll tell the world when I tell you guys
see everybody when they hear certain
things
is based on your journey in life right
see we all have a flight pattern in life
and right now I'm sitting here at this
table we have landed so all your
experiences right now is going to come
out
as we're talking if I say certain things
to you you're going to feel a certain
way based on your journey right that has
led you here so with the young lady she
said how she had got assaulted and that
um she this particular woman says she
felt like it was going to be unnecessary
to say anything because she felt like
the cops um
wouldn't take us seriously that she
wouldn't be playing and then um when I
was listening to her I said you know
what you write but I say I want to
listen once you listen to me now into
the world who's watching when I say that
you have an hour
what happens if you do it with an hour
whether that person whether cops believe
you or not
and that person who violated you gets
noticed that he did something wrong you
could probably take that person off the
street but if you
wait a year wait 30 years and he's
really a predator
you give him a chance to get more
victims
over the years but if you get a person
right then you might could get them off
the street you might can get them locked
up that day now everything is based some
women say oh I probably didn't want to
feel comfortable at that time right some
women say well I didn't have the
carriage until I saw her such and such
did when I saw her do it
that's what made me do it and
everybody's right so there's no wrong
thank you okay there's no wrong answer
so your thing your thing is just like yo
like my advice to you would be if not
you got an hour or you're [__] yes but
my advice to you would be immediately
reported immediately immediately report
it because you get that person so I
think I think that's a better way yeah I
think that's a lot better than how I I
feel like me and him
hey we were scrolling on I think the
shade rules like God damn what
and what you're saying is right it's not
what I said is how I said it right I I
do think that that's not bad advice yes
right yeah he's pretty much saying for
better chances to lock somebody up just
tell as quick as possible and if you're
a woman who's going through something
and maybe it's a family member or maybe
it's right more complicated and it takes
a little bit more there's no wrong
there's no wrong that's fair yeah
there's no wrong because and if I
offended anybody I apologize but because
I was right I just worded it the wrong
way that it everybody couldn't right
understand it that's important yes
they're very important yeah I remember
that we all hear stuff different so your
attention sometimes is people's
perception might take it differently so
no you got to clear your intentions up
yes that all makes sense